the importance of the new Phi 1 model
isn't just that it's small enough to be
on a smartphone set to be open sourced
and capable of interview level python
coding tasks its significance is also in
what the model tells us about the future
of language models and the timelines of
our march to human level intelligence I
spoke in depth with one of the authors
of the paper Ronan eldan to get you more
insights and I'm only going to cover the
best bits so let's start first thing to
notice is how small this model is at 1.3
billion parameters but what does that
number mean well for reference that's
about one percent the size of gpt3 which
was behind the original chat GPT
phenomenon and if recent rumors are to
be believed it's about a thousand times
smaller than the combined parameter
count of gpt4 so we're talking a tiny
model here that could fit on my Samsung
s23 we read that despite this small
scale Phi 1 attains a pass at 1 accuracy
that means past first time of 50 on
human eval testing python coding
challenges and Draco pathy of openai and
Tesla Fame said that we're probably
gonna see a lot more of this creative
scaling down work prioritizing data
quality and diversity over quantity
using synthetic data to create small but
highly capable expert models and the
author I spoke to actually retweeted
that and said for Skeptics the model
will be available on hugging face soon
give it a try back to the paper which
says everyone knows about scaling laws
adding more compute adding more data but
following the footsteps of eldan and Lee
in tiny stories which I'll get to in a
second we explore the Improvement that
can be obtained along a different axis
the quality of the data of course anyone
familiar with my Orca video will know
that data quality is super important but
let's get to this paper they mentioned
and I'm going to give you the 30 second
version of the paper co-authored by
Ronan they created a diverse and
synthetic data set of short stories
using GPT 3.5 and qpt4 and then they
train tiny 28 million parameter models
and smaller actually which as they say
are two orders of magnitude smaller than
gpt2 which was only 1.5 billion
parameters and by curating the synthetic
data carefully look at the difference in
results the ending of this story was so
much better on the tiny model trained on
this synthetic data set especially
compared to gpt2 which is so much bigger
but it says the soup is too old it's a
terrible ending to the story so what did
they do for Phi one well here is the
short version they filtered the stack
and stack Overflow to only get the most
teachable bits of code consisting of
about 6 billion tokens they then created
a synthetic textbook consisting of about
1 billion tokens of GPT 3.5 generated
python textbooks that's not even gpt4
then quite crucially they created a
small synthetic exercises data set
consisting of only 180 million tokens of
exercises and solutions now of course
other people have used the stack before
but as Ronan says I do think that from
the data we do have we are not even
close to extracting everything from it
and look at the results of this tiny 1.3
billion parameter model trained in this
way there have been only two models that
have scored more than 50 on human eval
pass at one that's wizard coder and of
course dpt4 but of course those models
are massively bigger and therefore much
more expensive to train and actually I
find this chart perhaps the most
interesting one of all in the entire
paper you can see so many Trends in one
diagram let me try to pick a few of
these out and remember the scores are
the percentage accuracy on human eval
think moderate level coding challenges
first look at the consistent increase
from when you just train on the filtered
stack versus on the synthetic code
textbook from 11 to 16 12 12 to 20 17-29
this could be the synthetic data Event
Horizon that Sam Altman talked about and
that code textbook was generated using
GPT 3.5 not even gpt4 next compare the
parameter count of the models 350
million on the left and in the center
and 1.3 billion on the right this one
isn't as big a surprise we knew that
increasing the parameters yields better
performance but nevertheless you can see
it vividly in action third and I think
this one is really fascinating look at
the difference between the left and the
center charts the only thing that really
changed was the number of GPU hours and
of course the number of tokens went from
26 billion to 76 billion but wait I
thought the data set size was fixed at 7
billion what gives well of course what's
happening is that they're passing over
the data multiple times this is called
training for more so-called epochs or
passes over the data so these aren't new
tokens they're the same tokens being
trained on more times as Ronan said to
me my personal impression is that many
people in the community thought that we
would never want to do more than like
one or two epochs because we'll start
overfitting and just for 20 seconds I
can't resist bringing in this paper that
they referenced in the textbooks paper
it's essentially talking about how you
can still scale language models even if
you run out of data and take a look at
these two diagrams they say training for
up to four epochs or passes is almost as
good as new data and it's only when you
get to around 40 epochs that repeating
is worthless obviously we don't know
about gpt4 but GT3 seems to be trained
on far less than that but there was one
final trend from this amazing set of
charts that I wanted to point out and
it's probably the most obvious one look
at the huge jump to the dark green bars
that's when they train the model on
those additional synthetic exercises
with Solutions the authors know that one
can only imagine how frustrating and
inefficient it would be for a human
learner to try to acquire wire coding
skills from such data sets like the
unfilled stack as they would have to
deal with a lot of noise ambiguity and
incompleteness in the data we
hypothesize that these issues also
affect the performance of language
models as they reduce the quality and
quantity of the signal that Maps natural
language to code let me quickly give you
a bit more detail about how they
filtered the stack they got about a
hundred thousand samples of the stack
and stack Overflow and then prompted
gpt4 to determine its educational value
or a student whose goal is to learn
basic coding Concepts they then use
those annotations to train a random
Forest classifier that predicts the
quality of a file using its output
embedding essentially a basic searching
mechanism to find out which parts of the
stack are the most educational but at
this point I want to pause and imagine
if they'd used a different prompt
imagine a future paper looking across a
different data set that paper could
prompt gpt4 to annotate the educational
value for student whose goal is to learn
French then you could have an amazing
French speaking model or maybe they
could get it to annotate which examples
would be most educational for learning
to predict the stock market and then
maybe train it on a small synthetic
textbook of successful previous examples
of predicting the stock market I'm just
saying this seems to be a model that
could be applied elsewhere and these
annotations here were the only times
they used Gypsy 4. the rest was GPC 3.5
and as Ronan says gpt4 is not only great
as something we can use directly for
better productivity but it's also a way
to get much better other models and
that's one thing I want openai anthropic
and Google to address the capability of
their models to train smaller models
here by the way is an example of the
kind of exercises and solutions that the
model was then fine-tuned on created of
course by GPT 3.5 and the authors note
that quite remarkably the model after
fine tuning on those fewer than 200
million tokens of exercises and
solutions also exhibits a substantial
Improvement in executing tasks that are
not featured in the fine-tuning data set
for example fine-tuning on codex sizes
unexpectedly improves the model's
ability to use external libraries such
as pygame even though our exercises do
not contain these libraries this
suggests that fine-tuning not only
improves the tasks we targeted but also
makes unrelated tasks easier to distill
it's this unexpectedness that I find
really interesting for example before
training Gypsy 4 did they expect the
emergent ability to do self-repair or
reflection according to this new paper
that ability is not found in GPT 3.5
going back to the Phi 1 paper the
authors admit that there remain a number
of limitations of our model compared to
larger models for code firstly Phi 1 is
specialized in Python coding which
restricts its versatility compared to
multi-language models secondly Phi 1
lacks the domain specific knowledge of
larger models such as programming with
specific apis or using less common
packages it's a bit like the more
classical narrow AI good at only a few
things furthermore due to the structured
nature of the data sets and the lack of
diversity in terms of language and style
it's less robust to stylistic variations
or errors in the prompt it's quite funny
if you make a grammatical mistake in
your prompt it does a lot worse but what
about this we also believe that
significant gains could be achieved by
using gpt4 to generate these synthetic
data instead of GPT 3.5 as we notice
that GPC 3.5 data has a high error rate
I asked Ronan about that speculating
that it's because gpt4 costs more and he
said yeah it costs more also gpt4 is
much slower but another reason is we
wanted to demonstrate something here
that you don't even need a smart model
like gpt4 even GPC 3.5 which isn't that
great at coding is enough so there you
go you could get even better results on
this using gpt4 but at the moment Gypsy
4 is a bit too slow before I get two
timelines some of you might have noticed
the wizard coder results and wondered
how that model did so well despite only
being 16 billion parameters which of
course is 10 times bigger than Phi 1.
well of course I read that paper too as
well as almost every paper referenced in
the textbooks paper The Secret of wizard
coder seems to have been increasing the
difficulty of the training data fine
tune the model with more difficult
examples EG if the original problem can
be solved with only a few logical steps
please add more reasoning steps maybe
complicate the input or deepen the
question or increase the reasoning
involved you can start to see the shared
themes of orca wizard Coda and Phi 1.
this could be what Sarah Constantine was
pointing to in the asterisk magazine
that I read yesterday I'm not sponsored
by them but it was a great issue so do
check it out she said rather than a
refutation of scaling laws or an
acceleration of their slope I think this
is more like a move in a different
direction altogether towards a Cambrian
explosion of little AIS used for
different purposes where getting good
performance on a task depends on the
quality of your task specific data set
like Phi 1 for python that could be
consistent with the state-of-the-art
continuing to progress steadily along
scaling law lines for quite some time
but it could also mean the economic
incentive towards ever bigger models
would diminish and would enter an
entirely New Era where AI progress would
not be driven primarily by semiconductor
scaling or Moore's Law this relates
directly to a tweet from the co-founder
of anthropic Jack Clark he said a world
where we can push a button and stop
larger compute things being built and
all focus on safety for a while is good
that is really interesting to hear from
someone at the top of an AGI lab but I
do have some questions for this policy
if we freeze compute wouldn't that
incentivize every company just to use
algorithmic progress to get more out of
the compute we do have and so on the
safety front I think it's far more
effective active public messaging to
focus on concrete things that everyone
can understand for example in this paper
from Oxford this week llms will in
particular lower barriers to biological
misuse biological design tools will
expand the capabilities of sophisticated
actors concretely bdts may enable the
creation of pandemic pathogens
substantially worse than anything seen
to date and could enable forms of more
predictable and targeted biological
weapons I think this is something that
everyone can get behind and as the paper
says it's been hypothesized that for
evolutionary reasons naturally emerging
pathogens feature a trade-off between
transmissibility that's how much they
spread and virulence that's how deadly
they are AI based bdts might generate
design capabilities that are able to
overcome this trade-off thus for the
first time humanity might face a
security threat from pathogens
substantially worse than anything nature
might create including pathogens capable
of posing an existential threat that to
be honest is my main safety concern
about back to the paper and timelines
here is another snippet of my
conversation with Ronan I said I just
feel like we are much closer to
something really transformative than the
public has quite realized and people
like open AI put out that in 10 years we
will have something as powerful as a
corporation I say three to five years
Ronan replied that depends on how much
resources are actually spent into
training bigger and bigger models I have
no idea what openai and Google are doing
right definitely if this is our main
goal I think it can easily be five years
I said or less Ronan replied or less I
feel like the bottleneck is maybe the
production of gpus and I mean it's not
just to produce the gpus you also have
to build the data centers and connect
them to electricity etc etc I think if
you have all that then yeah I don't see
the barrier with more data higher
quality data synthetic data better and
better algorithms and more and better
gpus and tpus that's what we mean when
we say we don't see a barrier of course
everyone has slightly different
definitions of AGI but almost everyone
agrees that the next five to ten years
are going to be the most critical in
seeing whether more data better data
better algorithms or just more and more
compute will lead to AGI or super
intelligence I loved how Carl Shulman
put it on the dwarkesh Patel podcast if
you generate like close to 10 million
dollars a year
out of the future version h100 and it
costs tens of thousands of dollars with
a huge profit margin now and profit
margin could could be reduced with like
load production that is a big difference
that that chip pays for itself almost
instantly and so you could you could
support
pain 10 times as much to have these Fabs
constructed more rapidly you could have
if AI is starting to be able to
contribute could have ai contributing
more of the skill technical work that
makes it hard for say Nvidia to suddenly
find thousands upon thousands of top
quality engineering hires if AI can
provide that now if AI hasn't reached
that level of performance then this is
how you can have things stall out and
like a world where AI progress stalls
out is one where you go to the 100
billion and then
over succeeding years trillion dollar uh
things software progress
um turns to start turns out to to stall
you lose the gains that you are getting
from moving researchers from other
fields lots of physicists and people
from other areas of computer science
have been going to AI but you sort of
tap out those resources uh because AI
becomes a larger proportion of the
research field and like okay you've put
in all of these inputs but they just
haven't yielded Ajay yet I think that
set of inputs probably would yield the
kind of AI capabilities needed for
intelligence explosion but if it doesn't
after we've exhausted this current scale
up of like increasing the share of our
economy that is trying to make AI if
that's not enough then after that you
have to wait for the slow grind of
things like General economic growth
population growth and such and so think
slow and that results in my credences
and this kind of advanced AI happening
to be relatively concentrated like over
the next 10 years compared to the rest
of the century because we just can't we
can't keep going with this rapid
redirection of resources into AI That's
that's a one-time thing thank you so
much for learning about Phi one with me
and as always thank you so much for
staying all the way to the end do try to
have a wonderful day